four years ago dirty water contaminated
with lead started flowing from Flint's
taps causing sickness and death while
officials denied there was a problem
well we're dead and gone these children
will suffer for what we failed to do now
officials insist the water is safe to
drink
but residents don't trust them how many
people have we buried and babies have
died because of this and we're just
supposed to get over it as an ordinary
citizen about poison one individual I
would be in prison and they poisoned an
entire city of people and no one is
being held accountable the state of
Michigan has stopped providing free
bottled water to Flint forcing people to
spend thousands of dollars on water to
drink cook bathe and even flush the
toilet and water bills here are already
some of the highest in the country
why should the people of Flint pay for
water that poisoned them
that they don't trust and in a lot of
cases they don't even use because the
water is safer
[Music]
it's crazy to think that it's been over
two years since we were last here in
Flint and being back here now it's clear
that not much has changed the last time
we visited things were in bad shape
they say some about the water won't be
faked in 2035 Wow the crisis began in
April 2014 when the city temporarily
switched its water source from Lake
Huron to the Flint River to save money
but the water from the river wasn't
properly treated so the pipes corroded
and leached lead discolored
foul-smelling water started flowing out
of taps despite complaints
city officials denied there was a
problem for almost two years before
declaring a state of emergency more than
a dozen people died while others lost
hair and developed rashes since then 15
officials have been charged some with
involuntary manslaughter on the
four-year anniversary of the day Flint's
water was switched residents were no
less angry I didn't know things like
this go on in America and now I'm 37
years old and disabled and worrying
about my kids every night like all of us
our Christina Murphy is a single mom of
three since the water crisis began she's
struggled to stay afloat so you're told
your water is fine you stopped getting
this free bottled water and now you have
to buy it in April Michigan Governor
Rick Snyder announced the state would
stop providing Flint with free bottled
water claiming nearly two years of test
results showed lower lead levels that
sparked outrage
Christina like other Flint residents
relies on filters even though she
doesn't trust the water she still has to
pay hundreds of dollars a month for it
my water was shut off last month and
they made me come up with 860 No 838
dollars
and I'm living off of like $600 a month
right now
Christina's youngest child is two
year-old Declan she was 16 weeks
pregnant with him when news broke about
led in the water as a newborn
Declan made headlines after his first
bath was given entirely with bottled
water so this baby has never known clean
water his whole life he only knows
bottled water bottled water or heavily
filtered water has he had any sort of
health side effects of the leg do you
know we do know that he could be
cognitively impaired but we won't find
out until he's like 3 or 4 years old
last year Christina had her children
screened for various toxins including
lead through hair follicle tests arsenic
is somewhere around 70 80 that is beyond
the 95th percentile
yeah the leads beyond and then the total
toxic representation is yeah as her
family reels from the effects of the
crisis
Christina's lost all faith in the
government what was the governor's words
to the mayor the other day get over it
well tell my my kids that you know
please Governor Snyder tell my kids
that's their faces to get over the fact
that they've been poisoned and that
their legs hurt and that they have night
sweats and that they shake sometimes and
that their mommy can't play with them
the way she used to because she's too
sick and we're just supposed to get over
it
[Music]
because so many of Flint's children are
exposed to lead there's now an entire
school created specifically to help them
Cummings Great Expectations serves 142
young ones ages 0 to 4 so each of these
children has been affected by lead every
single one in our building has been
affected by the water so they were part
of the water line from April 2014
through August 2016 hello checking
everybody out AFA site director Lindsey
carey showed us how classrooms double as
observation rooms and teachers are
trained to look out for symptoms of lead
poisoning so this is one of our Early
Head Start classrooms that has the
observation window where people can come
in and observe the classroom without
being intrusive on their day there's a
lot of different challenges that we see
we see some developmental delays whether
it becomes you know speech and language
the cognitive taking a little bit longer
to talk our kids really struggle in the
social areas we're seeing a lot of
asthma skin conditions from the exposure
to the lead in the water so how did you
feel when it was recently announced that
free bottled water will no longer be
provided to Flint residents yeah I'm not
gonna lie I cried a lot of people tell
me you know you've got to be so happy
that the water crisis is over now and my
response is always that blank stare of
it's not over
[Music]
in 2017 the US Census Bureau declared
Flint the poorest city in the country
for its size 40% of people here live
below the poverty line and it's so
difficult for Flint's poorest residents
to pay their water bills that
foreclosures are becoming more common
for most residents it's just another
result of a long history of neglect sir
Tanya Johnson has some of the highest
water bills in Flint in 2017 she
received a letter from the city stating
she owed ten thousand dollars in water
payments it was later reduced to six
thousand our records indicate that you
have a past due balance for the amount
of six thousand nine hundred and sixteen
dollars and then they say when you do
not pay the amount you incur the penalty
and our shut off list so they're
threatening to shut off your water yes
what are you gonna do I don't know sir
Tania's only income comes from Social
Security which has roughly eight hundred
dollars a month
her health is suffering she's had five
strokes since 2015 what do you think the
city or the state owes you right now
paid my bill I really do
give them that big water bill resolved
they'll be that much this is one of the
areas where they're replacing thousands
of contaminated pipes to remove any
traces of lead the work is scheduled to
be completed by 2020 now if you live in
a neighborhood that hasn't had its pipes
are placed yet chances are you're not
using the water but you're still getting
charged for it Hughie Newsom is Flint's
new chief financial officer he comes
from the private sector and supports the
city shutting off people's water for
lack of payment why should the people of
Flint pay for water that poisoned them
that they don't trust and in a lot of
cases they don't even use because the
water is safer we have worked so hard to
get to go from where we were at the
beginning of the crisis to now the
poverty in Flint is undeniable and
people are still reeling from being
poisoned by the leg of the water and yet
they have some of the highest water
bills in the country is that fair I
don't think it's fair but it's um
unfortunately right now it's a financial
reality and we're working very very
diligently to address that we've really
tried to communicate to residents that
you know if you're using the water you
have to pay for it if you don't pay for
other residents have to pay for it but
then other bad things happen the last
thing we want to do is to have someone
else control this a lot of people would
argue that they shouldn't have to pay
anything that someone else should step
in maybe the state and pay their water
bills well and you know I don't want to
get too deep into what the state shoots
should not mean doing you know people
when they're billed for water their bill
for water and sewer together you're
using the work there's no question
you're using it so you should also be
paying for that service as well so let's
not talk about what happened in the past
so that you can you know circumvent pain
for service that you're in that you're
that you have now
[Music]
but residents we spoke to still haven't
let go of the past
rapper IRA Dorsey who goes by bootleg
grew up here his group the Dayton family
has used music to call attention to the
entrenched poverty in Flint growing up
back in the early 90s this was a fluent
neighborhood I mean it was people
everywhere people were working for
General Motors and everybody income was
well and families were living good the
violence was real low and it was a fun
place to grow up back in Flint then it
was over 200,000 people here and now
it's down to like 80,000 people so this
is just a remnant of what Flint used to
be what is it justice for Flint look
like to you I would like to see people
being prosecuted because it me as an
ordinary citizen if I poison one
individual I would be in prison and they
poisoned an entire city of people and no
one is being held accountable not at the
level where the decisions are being made
Flint is still one of the most dangerous
cities in the u.s. according to FBI
statistics budget cuts have slashed
police and fire departments for locals
the water crisis is just another
systemic failure they let us down
the EPA stood by and left us out here to
die and that's the way we feel
bootleg song city of lead calls out
former and current officials for their
failure to adequately address the water
crisis this is not a third world country
we live in the wealthiest country in the
world and at the end of the day while
we're fighting battles overseas and in
other countries we need to invest in our
country
[Music]
hey guys it's Deena that's an update on
the Flint water crisis make sure you
come back next week I'll still be in
Michigan reporting on how Nestle is
getting a lot of water from the state
for cheap and folks aren't happy about
it in the meantime comment share and
like this video and please subscribe to
aj+